a carson city judge denying the trump
campaign's request to toss out the
election here in nevada
and proclaim the president the actual
winner we alerted you to this ruling in
the i-teams reporting inside the 8 news
now app
the judge saying lawyers for the
republicans failed to provide
any substantial evidence of fraud take a
listen to what their lawyer said in
court yesterday about
that now discredited evidence
in one month we have put together
striking evidence
that because of the lack of transparency
because things were rushed
this election
was unfortunately stolen well the judge
didn't buy that
writing in this 34-page ruling
republicans failed to provide any real
proof that quote
illegal votes were cast and counted and
not the amount that
had been talked about in court upwards
of 40 thousand
he also said depositions provided in
court amounted to hearsay
the state republican party says it will
now appeal to the state supreme court
we'll have a full rundown of the
allegations in a lawsuit on eight
newsnow dot com